with christian crayola fabi
what a game well first of all faviano
congratulations we are still
shell-shocked here in the studio how do
you feel after this armageddon
i can't say i'm really happy
i'm a little bit disgusted because uh
twice he played this opening
and it's uh i mean i get basically a
winning position out of the opening
and twice i ruined it um
and i'm just really
uh i mean you know you expect an
armageddon to be a bit of a mess but
the position i was get gifted out of the
opening
um
like it's it's really a shame to ruin
this
and
i i was playing terribly
um the logical end would have been to
lose this game but
um yeah at some point we just started
blitzing i didn't know what move it was
um but it was my only chance to flag him
did he know what move it was because we
saw him looking at
those monitors after
the end of the game i don't know he
might have had a rough idea that it was
close
i had a feeling that it was close
but
i didn't
it still hadn't felt like we had played
like a full end game to get to move 60.
so i
i figured that if he makes it it's going
to be
by move um but yeah at some point it was
just pure
well he also didn't play very
practically he allowed all this
confusion with bishop ea g6 and this was
the moment when he started to burn a few
seconds and i
got my chance to uh to flag him
but yeah overall i i'm not too happy
with it you said he gifted you a winning
position out of the opening in both
games today with the black pieces did
you speak with him about that did you
guys have any time in between games in
between the rapid games and the
armageddon or did everything just happen
so fast well i think it's a bit
uh strange to discuss openings with your
opponent during a match
and after it i just didn't want to
bother him you know i understand that
um it's it's probably quite emotional
especially since he had it
he had it in the bag so i didn't really
want to uh
you know talk chess with him
uh
abby uh you you mentioned the fact that
yourself that you came out of the
opening with really really a nice
position
i'm looking at this position that you
had you played the move bishop f4 which
was a bit of a surprise for alejandro
and i we were really focused on bishop
g5 i'm sure it was your first in in
intention but you backed off why well
this was just some sort of decision
making i i like i i thought he'll stack
the exchange for sure after bishop g5
yeah and
you know i thought my position should be
winning without allowing this where he
if he gets the dark squares and you can
imagine
some compensation although i'm sure he
doesn't
you know get have the time to coordinate
to get c5 knight c6 knight d4 everything
he wants but uh
but that's the reason i rejected it i
thought bishop f4 i'm getting h6 rook do
you want everything i see um
and then i i mean i blundered a4 later
on okay i think i was already miss
playing it
but at least i shouldn't give away my
free pawn
like this should be winning right
yes
we
thought it was you know winning also
yeah but as you say i mean you just
gave it up at a certain moment uh it did
these playoffs they they play havoc with
your nerves how do you stay
calm
i
i
don't
heart beating but i guess
with time you managed to stress a bit
better but yeah these these are
stressful
matches i did play a lot of armageddon
um norway in uh well not only in norway
but um but more recently at the end of
2021
i played a tournament and i think i
played like six armageddon games
because there was matches which and all
my matches seemed to end in armageddon
so
and um then i tied with rapport for
first place by points and so there was
like a final armageddon to decide the
the winner of the tournament
uh so
at least like i decided that i just like
to take white because um
oh it's probably a personal thing but i
prefer it what alejandro was saying as
well that in the armageddon somehow it's
nicer to have white
congratulations as you move on i mean
but wow what a way of uh
stepping across the winning uh the
finishing line as you say you kind of
fall you fall on your nose forward you
just flag him flag him flag him well
thank you favi congratulations on your
match victory at the end of the day
exactly you move on to the chances
yeah let's take a look at what that
happens we see this flag yet again
some hesitation
yasser from now on he's not pushing baby
baby
and this is the hesitation move right
here it was king c3 and not king d3 and
he
oh my god there it goes oh my gosh
that's
that is such all right let's take a look
then at the brackets in the championship
section champions bracket arrow